can I just say there have been some
really amazing anti-bullying videos over
the years you can't beat advice like
this hey Bob wanna paint your name no
thanks what are you a city it's hard not
to follow the crowd but sometimes that
path is just a dead end tips work great
in 1985 but it's the future now and
bullies have stepped up their game so
how about we stop kidding ourselves the
bullying is some sort of ancient ritual
then everyone is dealt with for
millennia upon millennia it's harder now
it's worse now luckily there's a new
book out called the Survival Guide to
bullying it's not written by some
psychologist who hasn't been a kid for
30 years it's written by a real bully
survivor one of us I'm talking about
Asia may rashi very recently survived
high school bullying and she did it with
very specific actionable things that
anyone could do right now lucky for you
we've got some of those tactics in this
video I'm drew Coolidge and it's time to
man your battle stations we're about to
end bullying this is hashtag news so
here's my first tip find your squad I'm
not talking about a step up style Dance
Crew you've got to earn that
I'm torquing right below the fray
now I don't want you to go join a gang
but you can join a club or a class full
of people with similar interests to
yours if you don't feel comfortable in
your school check out neighborhood
events or community college programs
open to younger teens whatever you
decide don't be afraid to jump in and
meet new people chances are they're
there because you have something in
common whether you're interested in
tennis or singing or video games or
hosting YouTube videos finding a group
of people who share your interest and
appreciate you can be key to getting
through life with bullies not only have
you just made a bunch of friends who
aren't gonna make fun of you since they
have the same interests as you but it's
a lot harder to pick on someone when
they roll with the freaking army of
fellow fencing enthusiasts or insert
your own interests there but still do it
with the same intense stare okay
now finding your people will be a big
help but if you're dealing with
something right now today and you need
to do something quick and here's your
best tactic for success tip number two I
like to call it the ancient art of
getting out of there now don't run away
from home or the people that care about
you but there's nothing shameful about
avoiding people who are bullying you
that's exactly what Will Smith did on
Fresh Prince of
I got in one little fight and my mom got
scared you moving with your auntie and
uncle in bel-air and he's doing fine you
can ask to be switched in different
classes or even change schools
altogether if you need to think of as
being your own superhero only your power
is being good at telling problems all
superheroes know that they need an ally
it's not tattling it's protecting
yourself with whatever means you
currently have
but despite the old way of thinking
bullying isn't a thing where you have to
just suck it up and deal with it protect
yourself get out of the bad situation
pick up your feet and go somewhere else
run it's not only okay it's good for you
with all that cardio you're gonna get
rich no I can tip number three be
yourself I know this sounds kind of lame
but it's actually really true a lot of
people think they get bullied because
they're different so they try to pretend
to be something they consider more
normal but nine out of ten bullies agree
when they're on the prowl looking for
someone to pick on it's the person who's
trying too hard to be someone they're
not that stands out the most it's like a
chameleon who tries to camouflage to
avoid predators but turns out he's only
good at looking like bacon sure it looks
different but that's not a look that's
gonna do him any favors when you're just
yourself the real you and you show what
things you like and dress how you want
to dress you not only don't seem like a
tasty victim to a bully predator but
you'll attract those potential friends
who look a lot like you so don't give up
playing chess or memorizing Eminem
hip-hop lyrics just because someone told
you it wasn't cool they aren't gonna
like you suddenly because you conform to
their standards and more importantly
giving up on things that make you happy
is not gonna make you happy
logic right but that's just a sample of
what's available in this sweet book
there's a link in the description
that'll show you how to get your hands
on this book it's got plenty more ideas
and it also reminds us that bullying may
not feel like it but it's temporary
middle school in high school do end and
then some really awesome stuff happens
maybe you'll go on to write a kick-ass
book before you're old enough to rent a
car like Asia here
how you doing Asia good drew how are you
I'm very good thanks for making me stand
here while you're talking the whole
episode any time so tell everyone why
you're here sorry I wrote this book
because I was bullied and
I wanted to be able to help kids who
were still going through it I'm not
talking about being bullied like a long
time ago I'm talking really recently you
know I was in high school and over time
I picked him a few tricks that really
worked so I wrote a book is it this book
it is I wrote this book because I was
bullied and I wanted to be able to help
kids get through the bullying and on to
create great lives for themselves and
this book is available now you can check
out the link in the description I
compiled all of my survival tactics and
the things that helped me get through
bullying into this book
so get through this time because you
know when it's all behind you life gets
to be so incredible and your life is
obviously turned out you're on hashtag
news I know seriously it's so much
better ok so if you have any tips that
have worked for you when dealing with
bullies please please please share them
in a comment so we can all learn for
them and if you're looking for help
dealing with bullies that like to hide
behind screens we have another video
with real actual advice that can help
you with cyberbullying check it out if
you guys have any questions feel free to
ask your friends and adults for help but
also you've got us you can talk to us in
the comments tweet at us tweet at me and
Asia with this hashtag right here this
one right here there's plenty of ways to
reach me in the description Instagram
Twitter Facebook so we can talk more
about this I'm Asian I rock I'm drew
Coolidge and we're here for you a super
heartfelt it's true I liked it actually
can I talk to you you said be your own
superhero I've been kind of working on
it I was thinking like superhero names
really I was thinking now I know my name
is Giroux what I do jason has more power
to it embrace who you are
[Music]